uh i'm w earl brown i played kenny and i
died in the first movie
trying to save nev from ghost base
i was courtney's cameraman and i got my
throat slit
and uh and i died on camera and my death
was one of them that
caused an x-rating initially that wes
had to trim some frames to get an
r what do i think my character would be
doing now if he didn't die
in the movie well uh kenny probably
would have worked his way up to a
producer uh possibly an executive in
tabloid media
and he probably would have died from
congestive heart failure due to his poor
dietary habits
while going through a metoo lawsuit
[Music]
what was my favorite treat at craft
services well
i gained a lot of weight before doing
the movie so i must say
it was pretty much everything at craft
services because i
ate everything i could get my hands on
however
my least favorite treat um from
uh from props department where the
cheetos i've never been a fan of the
chief puff thing
so that was why because i'm supposed to
be eating all the
time so i started the whole playing with
the cheese puffs simply because i didn't
want to eat them
so that little bit of business in the
movie was basically me
not wanting to eat that thing
you